let's get into that big story that's
been going around that everybody can't
stop talking about newsweek reports
white house says crack pipes never
included in safe smoking kits i think
this story is particularly interesting
to me because i can understand wanting
to
intervene to help people who are
addicted to drugs to lower drug
infection rates to get them into safe
environments and help them get off drugs
the problem i have with this story is
that for one i think the white house is
lying about not including crack pipes
and i think giving crack pipes to people
or meth pipes and other
drugs syringes will just increase the
amount that they're actually doing so i
just want to mention one thing in
reference to this story if you do a
google search and look up harm reduction
supplies and safe smoking kits glass
stems crack pipes and meth pipes are
typically included in them now that
we've gotten that out of the way i don't
know if um our good friends from
congress have any insights into the
story or what's going on is it true is
it false and what do you think about it
i would like to say that uh fact checker
itself i reject the phrase i mean it's a
synonym for corporate shill or leftist
propagandist amen so
that's my take on fact checkers well
believe a word they say no i don't
believe a word they say either and
actually i find it appalling that joe
biden and the biden administration would
uh
give out crack pipes in these safe
smoking kits you know we do want to see
people get off of drugs i think that's
extremely important but i think biden
doesn't care about drugs he doesn't care
about people dying fentanyl is coming
across our border at a
terrible rate
fentanyl poisoning is now the number one
cause of death
of ages 18 to 45 years old and so joe
biden's all for drug use right he's all
for fentanyl he's all for uh smoking
meth smoking crack whatever it may be
it's absolutely appalling but the one
thing he doesn't support the one safe
drug he doesn't support is ivermectin so
i think this is a serious problem well
as always people should be getting
medical advice from trusted medical
professionals and i don't care if it's a
politician i don't care if it's a
celebrity you got to get that advice
from somewhere else the story the part
of the story that makes me laugh is okay
let's just say for a minute all right
there's no crack pipes here right
they've denied it no crack pipes does
the safe smoking kit include meth pipes
then because that's typically involved
the issue is even snopes acknowledged
the point of this program is to give
priority to minorities
to smoke
these drugs
so that means that think about this for
two seconds like the bite administration
is basically saying we're going to be
funding
programs that distribute drugs and and
drug paraphernalia to minorities i don't
think that's going to solve the problem
of racism are they actually distributing
drugs as well or is this just a
paraphernalia program i think it's
paraphernalia okay did make sure it's
clear clarified like syringes and stuff
like that but if like i'll put it this
way if there's like a white dude he's a
drug addict there's like a black dude
he's a drug addict and your program says
give the drug the supplies to the to the
minority that means you're going to have
less white people doing drugs and more
minorities doing drugs that sounds
awfully racist or more more white people
getting sick from from dirty needles and
and that's also horrible and raising
wait a minute wait a minute have we we
haven't voted on any funding for this
how are they doing it
we've given them broad swaths i don't
know how they do it i don't remember
reading this in any building we have
voted on one thing though in our
judiciary committee
and that is to make sure there's parity
in drug sentencing laws between crack
and powder cocaine because
uh in the beginning
it was actually the the african-american
communities who wanted maximum sentences
for these evil people that were
destroying their communities for crack
they should
but then they decided that it was racist
to over prosecute crack in comparison to
powder cocaine so a lot of states have
made it uh made parity between the
sentencing laws between these two and so
we've had votes in congress to restore
parity to get rid of any racial bias i
don't think people should be going to
prison for doing drugs i think they need
help i don't know how do you guys feel
about that
i think drugs are so destructive i mean
like i said right now the drugs that are
coming across the border just a record
rate uh through the mexican cartels are
laced with fentanyl and if if young
people are dying if the number one cause
of death for young people is fentanyl
poisoning i think drugs are a real
problem i really do is it is it number
one it's number one number one cause of
death it's not coveted 19. it's fentanyl
poisoning no i think we have the
constitutional authority to regulate it
at the border
but uh let's be honest when they wanted
to outlaw alcohol
they recognized at the time they had to
do it through a constitutional amendment
so
states might be able to do this and the
feds might be able to do it at the
border but i don't think we have the
constitutional authority to ban
substances at the federal government
level yeah i mean honestly i agree i
don't i think you know the problem is we
talked about a bit last night
we want people to not do drugs
and so
personally i think locking people in
prison for imbibing something sounds
really really awful especially if it's
something hurting them and they're
addicted and they need help
so you look at these other countries you
know portugal was big but they offer
people help you know my understanding is
it's still illegal to do these things in
public
giving out these supplies and funding
the stuff seems like
they read a pamphlet about it and then
decided to throw money on it without
actually investigating what it's going
to do because it sounds good i just
watched leanna wen from cnn talking
about how think times are changing the
science has changed and things are
changing and now we got to think about
how depression and how like despair is
doing damage to people so maybe this is
a way to help people cope with their
despair because maybe drug addiction is
up i wouldn't be surprised sure joey
have a crack pipe
yeah well and also throughout the
pandemic deaths from drug overdoses have
increased yeah so a suicide yes it's
tragic it really is
but if it saves just one life right yeah
i love the fact on this though like you
were mentioning fact checkers isn't it
kind of crazy there at that point where
fact checkers for the most part
obscure the facts to make it harder for
you to understand what's going on mm-hmm
yeah that's
and the question is what is their
purpose and who is paying them i dug
deep into factcheck.org and and looked
at their corporate records and they
received funding from the robert wood
johnson foundation which holds two
billion dollars of j j stock which is a
vaccine manufacturer the money they
receive is earmarked for vaccine fact
checking what really yeah so i taught i
taunted them on twitter and dared them
to fact check me on on my facts on them
and so their fact checks
didn't deny the fact that they were
taking money from this organization as
two billion dollars of
vaccine manufacture stock they said that
i was wrong because the vaccine
manufacturer has no editorial con
control over what they say but i never
said that right and as if it matters to
be honest right they owned the fact
check program i didn't say they have
editorial control what's the name of the
company that's taking the 2 billion from
johnson johnson robert wood johnson they
they were started with johnson and
johnson stock it's one of the founders
of johnson and johnson and they say
they're trying to diversify it but the
reality is they still hold two billion
dollars and they're getting
money from that do you know how much of
it is earmarked for um propaganda
i guess if that's the right word well
they give it to factcheck.org
and their entire program which is
probably not a big program it's like one
leftist reporter from pennsylvania
somewhere
is funded with it and then they just pay
for ads with it or something like
facebook ads or they hire people yeah
they pay this one reporter who's not a
scientist so think about it the
taxpayers are funding the people to be
in charge of what's information and
what's misinformation what gets me is
that makes no sense if you draw a six on
a table and you ask one guy what is that
he says it's six the other guy says it's
a nine and then the fact checkers come
in they get to decide which one of us is
right and they get to decide who gets
banned who gets demonetized who gets
removed yep well and then here's what i
love about the science change like that
lyanna wen woman or whatever is that her
name yeah yes that's a cnn doctor she's
like the science changed and now all of
a sudden they're trying to reopen and
the kovid restrictions my problem with
this is
we have a ton of studies coming out of
india and sweden that say certain things
so just leave it at that
that's not the science changing that's
those studies are bad
then all of a sudden one study comes out
and they say oh look the science changed
we're going to change our policy
what no they're picking and choosing
what is the science apparently dr fauci
himself is the science and he decides
and then that's the direction they go
yeah i mean if you criticize him you're
criticizing science but yeah on the the
note of these fact checkers when you
look at snopes for example a couple
years ago there was a huge controversy
where they were fact checking the
babylon b which publishes satire
articles and part of the issue with that
is it was actually
demoting their content in the algorithm
and just to give you an insight into how
honest this organization is referring to
snopes they double down on this instead
of admitting that it was ridiculous to
fact check satire and they said we
conducted a study which showed that a
lot of people believe these articles are
real well this is what they did they
took headlines that were obviously jokes
and rewarded them to sound like they
weren't jokes so one example was
democrats vow to close dangerous gun
buying loophole known as the second
amendment and that was a babylon b
article
it was reworded by snopes to say cory
booker is one of several prominent
democrats to describe the second
amendment as a dangerous loophole that
allows people to buy guns and then they
asked people if they thought that was a
real story and when people said yes they
said see that means they believed the
satirical babylon b headline was true
it's true it's truly amazing isn't it
well they're in charge of the
information or at least they've put
themselves in charge of the information
but just as thomas was just pointing out
the taxpayers are funding
them to be in charge of the information
by the way quick story when the vaccines
first came out the pfizer data the top
line data was out there and the cdc
issued a report and said that it was the
vaccine
data showed that the vaccine was 92
percent efficacious if you'd already had
covid and i thought well that's a
remarkable claim
and so i went and looked at the data and
it showed it was there was actually a
negative correlation for those who had
already had covet if they took the
vaccine this is pfizer's own trial data
so i'm a congressman i called up the cdc
and they took my call surprising right
yeah and the director
in washington dc said i'll get my top
scientists on the line i said i think
it's a typo so she she calls me back
with her top scientists and she said
we're going to call you eagle eye massey
we don't know how we printed this we
it's a mistake we don't know how it made
it in here and i was like well okay well
you're going to fix it right oh yeah
we'll fix it and i said so are you going
to are you going to do an errata
are you going to change the pdf that's
up there like i got into the
technicalities
and so i thought it was all fixed
the vaccine comes out
older people in kentucky couldn't get it
because younger people were taking it
who had already had coveted
but the data was never fixed the data
was never a month later somebody said oh
the cdc says this i went back and looked
they never fixed the lie and the the lie
is obvious it's knowable today so you're
saying there's a negative correlative
data meaning that after someone received
the vax or if someone had received code
and then they got vaccine there was a
less was less resistance than if they
hadn't had covenant got the vaccine it
was minus seven percent but they had so
little data it's hard to draw any
conclusion like the fact that they even
claimed they could say it was 92 percent
was ridiculous this is early on earlier
this was when the vaccine first came out
this was early december december 14th of
2020 right well as it's gone on though
we've learned more but really the truth
is when there's talking about the
science changing like she was talking
about on cnn y'all it has nothing to do
with science it's all about polling it's
about politics and this is an election
year and this is why democrats are
starting to loosen up we saw new jersey
taking away their mass mandates other
states and they're easing off because
they know they're in trouble this is a
major issue parents do not want their
kids masked i will i will issue the
obligatory talk to your medical
professional about what's right for you
and
data changes so make sure you're double
checking a lot of the stuff because uh
you know we don't have anything pulled
up but uh youtube is very very gruesome
these days by the way i have a
recordings of those phone calls that's
what i was going to ask you do you
normally record everything when you make
calls to these people no i normally do
not it's not something i would ever do
with another congressman for instance
but you publish them uh i gave them to
cheryl atkinson who did sort of an
expose and she picked the portions of
the phone calls i mean there there's
like an hour of recordings because i
published five or six
i should just release them all yeah yeah
yeah absolutely thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you